What questions do you have for students throughout the world?
Well, I happen to be a person
that believes a lot in questions
because I really feel that actually questioning
is all we can really use as teachers
and inspire questioning in students,
in designers,
in creative people,
in people that try to promote change
is really all we can do.
My best question to students around the world
would really be,
"How do they inspire themselves
to question everything around them
as a starting point for creative processes,
for innovation,
for enabling to take their environment,
their world,
their class,
their surrounding
to the next step?"
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.